flâner dans les arbres avec vue sur la
cathédrale de chartres
l'attraction vient d'ouvrir il ya quinze
jours en plein centre ville
des câbles des corps des échelles
partout un jeu d'enfant
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire ouais ça
m'a déjà fait
tu trouves ça dure facilement rang n'a
cessé vraiment à ce qu'ils ont fait et
c'était vraiment une bonne idée à rennes
pour animer donné par donner un peu
d'eux d'animation dans la ville et
franchement c'est top
[Musique]
m
en fait ce sont plutôt les grands qu'il
faut rassurer je vais devoir me manquait
là mais je trouve du courage là deux
classes du collège voisins sont venus à
pied et n'écoutant que son courage cette
prof de sport s'est équipé les élèves
sont ravis après cette période de co
vide un peu particulière voilà ont
trouvé ça super de pouvoir leur proposer
cette activité
c'est l'un des trois accro branches les
plus urbains du monde avec même une
tyrolienne au dessus du boulevard que
nous avons testé pour vous on voit les
voitures passer c'est clair que ça fait
c'est jouable sur nos émotions après
l'accroc vend ses traits psychologiques
une fois qu'on l'a fait une fois deux
fois on le sent plus passer question
distance sanitaires on est mieux ici
qu'en classe il n'y a plus qu'à espérer
qu'un jour il fasse beau